die beschreibung von dem video von alter
ich bin auf den server gegangen ich da
steht judith allem eine items sind weg
junge warum warum junge was ist hier los
war dass ihr gefalle oder was war das
megaprojekt immer wieder unterhaltsam
auch wenn ich nicht viel verstehe ich
habe keinen plan von magie und technik
doch dank ihr weißes bescheid nach
langen videos geguckt und es wird schon
wieder helen yu na bitte es geht ja um
starcraft warcraft streitkräfte zu dem
run crafter die beschreibung von dem
video von ich will auf den server
gegangen ich da steht judith allem eine
items sind weg junge warum wortgewalt
warum junge was ist hier los war dass
ihnen gefalle oder was war das das heißt
alle meine items sind weg alle meine
items sind weg sind schön
keystone die sind alle weg ich weiß
nicht was das war diesen alle weg also
komplett junge meine kann alles weg was
für wechsel alles ist weg einfach es ist
es ist einfach alles weg ich weiß nicht
warum es ist einfach alles weg ist er
verabschiede mich ist nicht wahr ich
dich nicht
die haben jetzt einfach alles weg was
zur hölle nein wie kacke das ist jetzt
noch einer etwas umgestellt bei mir hey
junge wehr war das alter alter es ist
einfach alles ich habe keine anderen
sachen
ich habe als junge ich hatte alle
möglichen sachen in meinem in berzona
marotte kann ja ich hatte alles ich habe
zwei portal ganz glaube ich ja ich hab
zwei junge aber ich hatte halt alles so
nah nur selber quantum hose alles
und portable holaus junge warum war er
tot
alter steht irgendwie so ein ding
jederzeit nix dass sie getötet hat gar
nichts ich kommt drauf geteilt dann
lagen da fünf levels und wenn nicht der
junge war im alter ich habe keine ahnung
bestimmung lustiger troll von niemandem
er verletzt sich also ich verstehe es
nicht mehr was aus diesem projekt
geworden ist warum werde ich jetzt
einfach um alter das alter das ist kacke
das richtige weg vor allem jetpack junge
jetpack ich kann nicht ruhig junge jack
ist ungefähr gar nichts wert gegen
quantum rüstung uns noch ja aber ich
kann nicht mehr herum fliegen junge das
ist alter warte vielleicht ist es gerade
online
und nein die folge muss online community
sich das angucken können auch scheiße
hier hab ich denn jetzt was ihr seht
oder scheiße alter was mache ich denn
jetzt mann
ich hab keine ahnung bach [ __ ] das recht
behinderter junge das ist sich scheiße
des todes schreib doch mal in die
kommentare warum nicht ihr einmal das
oder schreibt man in die conti von euch
in die gruppe von mega projekt welcher
buchen sollen das war er aber nein das
kann doch gar niemand gewesen sein wenn
da nicht mal irgendwo eine maschinerie
oder sowas steht die ich bin einfach
gestorben ihr vielleicht wisst ihr das
ja dass irgendwer war oder so aber keine
ahnung alter einfach tot bist du darauf
gekommen da stand direkt user direkt ich
kann es dir zeigen ich kann es dir
zeigen bleibt nachher der aufnahme die
folge ihr habt ja 3006 geschafft
deswegen kommt die folge heute abend
noch du hast du hast keinen schaden
bekommen oder sein
ich bin drauf gegangen da greift michael
an junge ich hab echt heftigere probleme
als gleite sperrigen jungen ist es
scheiße alte das ist kacke des todes das
recht behinderter mann was mache ich
denn jetzt was hatte ich dann alles mit
portable hohl und nach konnte umrüstung
das heftigste einfach aber auch keine
fackeln ein junge wie kaka alter und
jetzt auch diese scheiße dass ich mir
das jetzt wieder irgendwie zurückzieht
muss beziehungsweise ich muss wieder
zurückziehen weil ich bin ja nicht
schuld an dem tod
ich war am ende der letzten aufnahme
dabei und jetzt gerade eben als die
aufnahme angefangen hat also es kann
einfach nichts gewesen sein letztendlich
kann es bezeugen dass das lokal damit
nichts zu tun hat weil es das muss
irgendwie lustiger toll gewesen sein
also ein ganz lustiger ich mache da
passiert etwas wo bis ich die sachen
dann zurück hat irgendwie was kannst du
kannst ja noch sein lässt du vielleicht
keine ahnung im block respond bist oder
sowas
es kann nix seien alle erstickt man doch
ja dann würde ich auch erstmal so talk
talk talk weiter so nach der zeit oder
vielleicht nein nein vielleicht keiner
hat irgendeinen hätte es kann aber auch
nicht sein dass irgendein dingen ein
einer der op hat oder so was einst so
kann
aber das sei schade das kann ich darin
er ist kann doch gar nicht sein so
komisch einfach mal mit ich kümmere mich
jetzt erstmal eigentlich wollten wir
fragen beantwortet und so das alles ja
genau ich kann mir die seite öffnen wenn
du willst ja deswegen ich mache mir ein
paar mal jetpack wir wollten ja auch man
das aber jetzt echt scheiße
es ist richtig scheiße hier aber das
kann ja auch nicht sein kriegst du in
sachen schon wieder
ja aber es ist halt jetzt gerade für die
aufnahme halten jetzt erstmals neun
machen muss sorry leute aber das tut mir
leid da braucht jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie wenn ihr schreibt oder nicht
jetzt weiß jetzt gar nicht aber wenn
jetzt leute die schreiben dann verstehe
ich so was echt nicht wenn jetzt mein
werte die heute die sachen zurück
gelegen dass also das ist doch hast du
den kannst du entschieden
aber kann man die sachen zurückholen du
kannst du mir items an machen
eigentlich kann ich nicht bin ja kein
okay nein dem motto funktioniert doch
oder leihen kann ich nicht auf dem motto
nein natürlich nicht alters und jeder
ich dachte ich dachte das wäre nur wenn
die teams wäre nur im im ressort wie
auch immer der heißen deshalb kann man
nichts nämlich darf da kann man immer
ärgerlich naja ich rufe mal dass da
etwas weshalb ich halt eben so gelacht
habe ich habe meine beschreibung
kopieren wollen und bei meinem in tron
in der lage die diese frau ja so ein
komisches zeug und auf einmal waren halt
die untertitel an und die lage irgendwie
so ein scheiß was man nicht versteht
und wer will amazon scheiß jetzt die
sängerin davon meine platte goethe und
die untere drittel zeigen einfach
während dem ganzen intro an obst obst
ist ob im haus wenn man den bau spricht
ja das lied heißt obst als stopp probst
also ich verstehe nicht warum ein nfs zu
wenig power hat die tablette auf einmal
ich habe gesehen dass das du auf einem
dings eine fackel drauf hatte
ich weiß nicht ob die durchlässig ist
fackeln jung ich brauche eigentlich erst
mal mein board wilde hummeln alter das
ist das wichtigste
ja klar damit die wende durch kann man
so auf zack alter es ist alles so
wichtig ja vor allem konnte rüstung
portable holen sonst noch alles mit
leute wenn ihr ganz nett seid oder max
einfach dann schauen wir damit schon die
letzte aufnahme und dann kannst du
gleich wieder die kommentare angehen
weil
fleißig fragen wieder zwei reporter
gestellt ihr könnt jetzt immer wenn max
dabei fragen stellen wie harry potter
beim axa dabei ist dann beantworten wie
die und dem konto schreiben was ich
jetzt hier noch so machen soll am
technik weil ich habe nicht das ist wenn
sie nicht mehr ich will ich würde
vorschlagen dass irgendein admin die
einfach hilft die sachen wieder
zurückzunehmen also dass du dir die
sachen zurück gibt es auch keinen
schäden oder so ja wir einfach nur weil
du kannst du nichts dafür ich war
wirklich von anfang an dabei ja aber ich
habe jetzt auch herr bock das in die
gruppe zu schreiben hier während der
aufnahme ich mach das nach der aufnahme
einfach und jetzt müssen wir halt
erstmal ein bisschen damit leben
allerdings bei electric jetpack langsam
ich gehe jetzt erstmal zu verbrauchen
noch long von bruce jenner ist der top
kommentar unter dem video ist krankhaft
1 megapixel
ja du bist ja schon dabei als jede
unterstützung ja genau ich bin selig
unterstütze ich muss die leute die am
meisten spam alte hallen voll
beansprucht spd mann und ich muss mir
das jetzt alles machen sonst kann ich
hier nichts machen alter ich erteile ihr
die erlaubnis der die sachen zu cheaten
der marken work travel stimmt das kann
ich machen
bis du hast du echt machen junge leute
wenn sich jetzt einer beschwert alter
ich begegne ich klatsche in dieses
gesicht wenn ihr jetzt gescheitert ist
echt 20 macht das jetzt erstmal nur für
den moment dass ich hier so ein paar
sachen
denn was heute die kannst du die sachen
wieder zurückgeben wenn die idee der
links hilft der mensch
ok ok
sein auto ist übrigens mein auto das hat
mir allerdings geschickt hype bevor es
dir gemacht hat hat sie gemeint ob es
korrekt ist ob es gut ist immer noch
frisch ist mit meinem namen reduziert
wenn ich bin da day ist nicht gut
wie komme ich wollte einfach weiß park
auf einer von den dreien intro ist
direkt wenn er dann aber er macht das
nicht mehr
ok heute ist echt geil also ich sehe
gerade einen ein ja ein punkt da wurde
das inventar jakub relativ weit am ende
halten ja genau also zwei minuten
verändert das sind dann bis bis dahin
ändert nichts mehr im inventar also 70
pfeile hast du einen bogen drei knochen
43 einmal 43 fackeln einmal 53 fackel
zwei dia schaufeln dann ne portal gun
karotten ein nano say berne der
spitzhacke mache ich obsidian meter
heute ich kann ihnen schon hast du
gehört was du als hat ist die
wertvollste sachen würde ich sagen
nano sable räuber habe ich aber schon
wieder portable whole lotta love wichtig
und portugal portugal dann hatte ich eh
2 aber dies trotzdem irgendwie teune ja
ja ich werde sachen zurück kriegen aber
ich möchte jetzt einfach was machen weil
bisher keiner was regel dauert jahre
also ich soll schauen ob sie die
anbieter ja wie ich hab sie dann uns
jupiter mache ja ich mache hier gerade
schon mal die grundkonstruktion
verlangen voll gut sonst verbraucher 22
stimmen
ach mir soll bei seite gehen dieser
scheiß shops in ganz sind 26 grad heftig
alter wahrscheinlich weil dein internet
nicht klarkommt darauf dass wir zum
internet ist und in skype hat eine perle
die leitung in fünf tagen endlich fünf
tage bequem wie mache ich also oben
links 1 mitte links 1 dann lässt du die
zwei in der mitte also die zwei zwischen
den frei und rechts wieder verstehst du
das ist die idee sinan oben links und
dann mitte links dann oben rechts mitte
rechts ok zwölf jahren alt natürlich ich
habe zwei long for booty pakets
nebeneinander so meint man ihn vorher
ist ab sofort der obst zum öffnen ist
das video und girlies mir ein paar
fragen will ja genau ich habe meine
sachen erstmal so grundsätzlich wieder
zurück hat es nicht lange gedauert aber
ist als ärgerlich alter des todes also
einer schreibt mich hatte 24 jahren eine
schreibt er gibt 13 millionen 999 1999
euro 99 cent für diesel von mir aus
alles war sky
schließlich könnten ich könnte ihnen
eine schreibt 50 cent der andere
schreibt ganz ganz vielen nullen
und dann 12 1 cent
max was gott kurzweil kaum jemanden
fragt ich mag fragen halte ich einen
cent sondern nahe genug an übels magst
du hast übels beherbergte ich heftig
heftig hörst du nicht sag mal bitte
genau wenn ich jetzt zu ende gesprochen
aber sag's mit penis den ist okay gut
platzieren früher nicht fragt so fragte
fragte du redest einfach weiter auf
einmal so voll von bagdad verantwortete
17 -sieg und später ich dachte wo bin
ich hier
aha die erste frage zu harry potter
lautet wie lang ist harry shum mit
schwarzem chance das schon heftig alter
da spreche ich aus erfahrung
30 zentimeter er ist ordentlich aber
dass der für ein bisschen bin okay dann
schreibt da direkt darunter das hat
nichts mit fragen zu tun steht fragt
mail on trial on lp luca du klingst wie
angela merkel beim döner fressen
hey wie angela merkel köhler frist
weiter jede leute was haltet ihr davon
wenn wir noch mal so ein bisschen fragen
machen und sorgt quatscht schreibt mal
in die comments ich bin das letzte mal
übrigens pervers leise gewesen und eine
aufnahme
ja du bist immer ein bisschen weise aber
dann ist mein klub sonst auch so viel
platz in unseren betten zu kommen gehört
steht harry potter fragen wann bin ich
in der richtigen folge nämlich sind die
böse war das 109 oder 100 abreise die
letzte oder die vorletzte folge der
stimmen mit fackelt auch funktioniert
nicht
da ist nix es gibt einige böcke es
natürlich lästige abwasser ist
durchlässigen glas dem alle geschrieben
sind das glas drüber hatten gras drüber
jeder möchte als glas top kill ich hab
kein glas ich habe ich nur zwei
glasglocke alter die kennen das hin
wie mache ich gleich meter klar auf der
seite muss sie zu so einem zu einer
raute anordnung in der mitte frei 32
mutter sonst auch so gefragt aha da
fragt eine wert zerstörte den letzten
horkrux und mit was firma harry potter
hier welche reporter mit sich selbst
falsch natürlich harry potter ist der
der deswegen musste sich selbst
zerstören pastor aus der scheiße wenn
man keine kontrolle hat alter mann sein
wird weiß fernseher terry wieder
zurückgebracht zu diesem zu dieser
schlachten wollen natürlich so zur schau
stellen und erlebt aber noch nadine i
und ist eine schlange und dies auch im
nachwuchs und newel tötet die mit dem
schwert angegriffen
also mein lieber alles verloren ist
verloren
ladet euch auf meine sachen das lässt
sich einfach mal nicht auf so lässt sich
das alles nicht auf kommentiert ich
schwöre dass mir fällt hatten so druck
ja ich hab den linken die beschreibung
gepackt zwei videos 22 was hat kefir
oben eigentlich pimmel [ __ ] teils
geheime pace was ist das warum sind
jedoch ein bisschen jetzt einfach mal
geändert fest da nutze ich dir einfach
mit alter steht mit einem gemeindehaus
das ist eine schöne frage hier
okay er weckt man die karte des
betreibers und wie löst man sie wieder
außerdem von wem wurde sie erschaffen
richtiger name und spitzen und ist eine
sehr ausführliche frage also wenn man
erweckt ihn indem man sagt ich schwöre
feierlich ich bin ein tunichtgut ehrlich
ja und man lässt die in dem man sagt man
das ernsthaft so ich schwöre ja und man
möchte indem man sagt nächste tag
begangen
geschaffen wurde die von von an diesen
drei homeboys und zwar von remus lupin
läuft schon so ein bisschen dann von
sirius black und war daher das ist
schwierig die crew und james potter und
die juni katzenschwanz und krone.at ist
sieger des black weil es hier so nah
niemals und kann sich den läufern
schwanz war damals dieses team von honda
peter matic vom schwanz dieser wunde
soll das größte wechselzeit man in der
welt schüler die keiner denn jetzt im
vernünftigen eigenen das so einfach mit
wolle hat meine frage einer fragt was
bedeutet eigentlich dieses tam tam ist
glaube ich türkisch für so kann so heißt
ich als so hässlich aber das sagt man so
etwas ja einfach mal cool sind riesig
haben und ich habe noch mit helium
deswegen kommt als auch mit helium rein
und das wird jetzt ein erweiterter
moment papa ruft seine schwester cool
ich lebe auf die länder
einer fragt edu luca
doch ist hier die sogar für dich die
frage zu luca harry potter frage wie
heißt harry potter mit vornamen und
gehörten seine eltern punkt harry peter
harry potter oder herr junge sein vater
wie heißt der noch mal habe ich doch
eben gesagt ja ich weiß ich weiß auch
wie der heißt normalerweise chain bis
villingen
der heißt james james potter wenn mutter
heißt
nein keine ahnung seine mutter harry
potter frage wie heißt harry potter mit
vornamen sie machen ja ein konkurs der
diss track macht auch ein kräftiges beck
wieder eine gute idee von einem
unberührten jungen geschafft hätten
als antwort penner alltag beiseite mit
ihm ich habe eine axt
dann machen wir bieten marie distrikt
ging mich ja als man mir einen bus an
erinnern wir wissen will okay dann ist
rot wir brauchen richtige richtigen beat
alter jakabos aneinander haften was der
denn nicht so dings ist jetzt in meine
sonnenbrille
klar aber ist ja ist das copyright
genauso wie die anderen auch wenn du nur
instrumental hast dann passt das
herrlich okay ich fand ich fange dann an
ich hoffe ich bin meine sonnenbrille
konkreter und krankhafter ezb froh dich
ja 2013
die alos nicht du bist doch du hast
gesagt du als anfang an vorne
du hast doch hat gesagt wird anfangs zum
ordentlichen dass man gleich noch mal
von vorne anfängt dann natürlich hast du
okay ja ich mal wieder spaß die web haft
droht bis du bist droht was laberst du
du stinkst nachkommen main statt
wir wissen dich jetzt an vorgegeben
zusammen kontrakten ich glaube verwehrt
auf dem beat nicht entwickelte kraft
nicht immer weiter immer weiter
nun übernimmt der steuer boscos roth
will ich komme in deinen hut tief der
scheidenpilz dann kannst du nicht mehr
blicken
dies kann als er dann läufst du dir auf
jeden fall nicht mehr
wir kommen deine stadt entwickeln wir
dich wegkommt rammler los okay sozusagen
das war krass genug würde das gar nicht
so der beat oder das war auf jeden fall
nicht unser wie delta das war so
schlecht der bi zumindest war mäßig
stark ja stimmen wie tony stark wo ich
ja ich glaube ich habe meisten eltern
aber der beat wir einfach nicht auf
unserem niveau der anbieter erreichen
der stop face off jetzt aber
nimmt die eigentlich aus wie pervers
geppert sind wenn sie die besten alter
die besten der besten
am besten kann strafbar und traumhafter
ihr zicken webtrekk 2.0 coni am steuer
pro tritt das rotwild roth willst du
trägst ein stich in deine milch das war
mein einziges align jetzt ist meint eck
vorbei mit ok und pils das geht bei dir
mir egal was du sagst ich fick dich egal
was du sagst egal was du mache ich auch
in die mega projekt du was willst du
damit seinen kopf da stellen sich roth
kaffeebraun pilz hat doppelt so viel wie
du bist ok dass wir zu wirken dein leben
wert oder du gehörst du dich frau immer
weiter getestet von uns kommt raus wie
soll er sich trauen
okay du bist des todes jetzt jetzt dass
du verloren mein leben verloren
jetzt muss entdeckt ist ja und ich bin
wieder bei ihm gibt eine urig die
wanderhure
das war es eigentlich schon
jetzt eigentlich wieder von der folge
junge jetzt habe ich jetzt im
wintergarten nicht ob ich vorn das
wirklich um ihr zum wintergarten war das
zeigt euch das umformen so ich mache
mich hier noch die wolle weg möchte
einfach so raunt blabla oder ist es
besser wenn das so ist es besser
ich mach da treppen runter ich weiß wenn
ich was das bringt aber aber das machen
was in der nächsten folge ich mache das
ich lasse es jetzt erstmal so offen
damit wie das so mit ich das nächste mal
so weißt du da muss doch was machen
ich versuche dann irgendwann meine items
zurückzuholen werde ich auch eigentlich
hinkriegen alter das kann ja nicht sein
dass ich einfach sterben ja ich habe mir
ein bisschen eisen geholt aber nicht
viel reisen du hast du dir jetzt voll
gut zu tun aber das habe ich meine
eigenen sachen macht will auch nicht so
jetzt hier um sport ein wenig geschafft
aber wir waren viele labern und davon
bleiben wir sind hier nicht mehr einfach
so wir sind dann sterbe wegen hunger und
eben hier aber du kannst hier leute dann
würde ich sagen wenn ihr mehr wollt so
folgen so max und mir mega projekts
dann geht einfach in die kommentare was
den erzählungsband spaß
ich hätte mir entwickeln ein gibt
natürlich kein display gibt natürlich
den mag ich button einmal reicht
übrigens braucht da nicht von spam und
schreiben uns mal distrikts gegen roth
pilzen die kommentare vielleicht
erwähnen die besten beschreibt er das
ist eine geile idee schreibt
irgendwelche lions in die kommentare
aber ich schreibe nicht rot ist dass wir
die lions daraus haben und wird dessen
ihnen das nächste mal antun sagt ob das
freestyle wäre ja und wenn ihr richtig
geilen lasse ich das einfach eine geile
vergleiche und so richtig dann sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder ciao